Cameron Balloons is the world's largest manufacturer of hot - air balloons and hot - air airships.
However,...
...they are perhaps best - known for their special shape balloons...
...and balloons that have also been used for making around the world record attempts.
In 1999, Cameron Balloons made the Breitling Orbiter,...
...the balloon that made aviation history by flying right around the world.
Bath is considered to be the most romantic city in the UK.
In the 18th century, it became a magnet for fashionable society...
...and today is once again attracting romantics from all over the country.
Over fifty percent of the weddings that take place in Bath...
...are for people who do  not live there.
As the city in England to be the UNESCO  designation of World Heritage Site,...
...Bath boasts splendid 18th century architecture...
...set against a backdrop of some of the most picturesque countryside in Britain.
Wandering through the narrow Georgian streets,...
...it is easy  to imagine life in a more leisurely era.
For those planning a spectacular treat,...
...a hot - air balloon over the city and  adjoining countryside would turn any woman's heart.
At Lucknam Park the  fragrant walled garden is a hotbed for proposals,...
... and with their equestrian center,...
...they can provide a couple of horses to gallop off into the sunset.